please welcome the glorious
jennifer goodwin elisa kook and maggie q
[Applause]
hi i am
oh my god i'm so excited to see you guys
first of all jennifer
we were lucky enough to be in a film
that
i still will watch every single time
it's on tv and was just the best filming
experience he's just not that into you
we had so much fun making it
it's
good advice too it's
you know
you had a story jennifer i think that
actually like
was helpful
from the movie
with justin will you tell me about that
yes my i was like living the movie
we had made he's just not that into you
and justin and i have been friends for
21 years that's right
and we were at a bar
discussing a man and he was doing that
thing where he'd be really flirty and
invite me to go get a drink and cancel
at the last minute
and nothing was ever coming to fruition
and i was sitting at a bar and i was
discussing this with justin
and how do i get through and someone
actually came up to us at our booth and
said
are you guys promoting your new movie is
this like a scene that you're doing to
promote he's just not that into you and
it took that for me to realize the guy
was not into me i mean i still reference
the lines and behavior in that movie all
the time it's so helpful um maggie i'm
such a fan of yours um and
i loved this story about and i didn't
know this with all that i think i know
about you about jackie chan
yeah i mean he he had a management
company i was one of his like artists i
mean they call them overseas and um
i was like the girl that they sort of
trained and decided was going to um
uh work in in in action films overseas
and and that's what i did and mind you
i i don't know why i was the girl i had
no experience people think because i'm
i'm mixed race i'm half asian people
think like i grew up doing martial arts
because i'm half asian i did not
at all i was a runner and a swimmer and
like i just i didn't there was no i had
none of that background i just i just
worked really hard
i mean i've seen you in action movies
maggie i won't hear it you are literally
like you are an action star you have got
moves for days i see why they picked you
it's a no-brainer
um okay eliza i wanted to ask you this
question because it was one of my
favorite stories um reading about you
and it happens to be about the one
that took place
in a certain place in times square
yeah i was a bathroom attendant in times
square
okay tell me everything
no i mean i should have i should have
probably signed an nba before like
like taking that job
but you didn't so spill
correct so i only took that job because
um
i wanted to be where they were doing the
snl after parties did you
see anything like
that comes to mind
there was a lot of hair holding
like
hey girlfriends okay exactly there was
just a lot of there was so many grunting
noises that
don't sound like they're coming from a
human and i'm like i'm like what is
going on what's happening and i thought
like maybe i needed to help somebody but
no no nobody nobody's looking for that
um now pivoting is about friendship
which
for me i i feel like i've survived
everything in my life
with and through and because of my
friends jennifer what does friendship
mean to you
and what did you try to bring into the
show
oh my gosh i am a girls girl
as you know and in fact the second
someone tells me they only have guy
friends like all my red flags go up
i love women who love women
and i feel like this this is what this
show is and i've been been very pleased
that men seem to be responding
but to me this is women's friendships at
their most contemporary and messy and
embarrassing and body and raw and that's
what i look for in my own friendships
like i i want to be able to be my
unabashed self and be vulnerable and ask
stupid questions and i feel like that's
the only way i'm going to become a
better person and my girlfriends make me
a better person eliza what does
friendship mean to you and what was
something that was like vital for you
to see about friendship in the show
well i
did grow up with brothers so i didn't
have any sisters and i didn't have
i live on a mountain and tapanga with
with two dogs so i
i
i now in the i would say
in the past like six years i like it's
been all female
friends and i
i feel like the most beautiful thing is
that i came the last show i was on was
all men and then i brought in this
beautiful like these two women that i
just like hold that energy and i get to
see myself in both of them and then it
makes me look at myself more in a way
that maybe i can improve or this or that
whatever it is i
i learn from them i love that point
maggie
what is important about friendship for
you and that you thought you could
uniquely bring to this with your
character i mean for me i just you know
you always love your family and and your
family is always going to be you know at
a certain level of importance in your
life but you don't
choose them and and the thing that's
wonderful about friendships is that you
do and that
when they're chosen they become
something that is um just invaluable
because it's not something that you have
to inherit right this is something that
like you know as an adult you go no
you're my people you're my people and
for this show i sort of felt like like
with sarah our art creator liz was
telling me like well you're designed
around my friend i forget what her name
is but she said who just says the things
that no one can believe that is being
said i love those people
kind of looks at her and is like did you
just why and um and i think that there's
there's such value in those people
because
they genuinely don't feel like they're
doing anything wrong because they're
like well if i'm not truthful i'm not
being helpful right
and that's that's what the character
brings and i sort of feel like i have a
little of that in my i'm nicer than
sarah like i'll i'll play people because
i care about their feelings and i don't
want them to feel bad that may not
necessarily be the correct approach but
um in the show she's just that person
like she doesn't really have a filter
and i i just those people make me laugh
in life so i hope sarah does that for
people me too i love all of your
perspectives on friendship that is so
awesome and i agree with each and every
one of you
[Music]